basically the world is this incredibly
rich and complex place with all sorts of
very very interesting complicated things
happening around us skin folding
clothing folding hair flowing in the
wind and my research attempts to capture
these phenomena and simulate them in
real time on commodity hardware and the
way that we're doing that is by studying
these types of phenomena and trying to
distill in some sense the simplest model
which will simulate them and it turns
out that you can sort of find
astonishingly simple models and then
allow people not only to see we also to
interact with these kinds of phenomenon
in real time these kinds of simulations
are used all the time in things like for
designing new airplane wings or for
figuring out what the weather will be
tomorrow but they're sort of locked away
at in these like super computers and
we're trying to take those exact
algorithms and put them in the hands of
like a five-year-old and be like what
can you do with this right in the case
of the protein folding game what we're
doing is we're saying help us solve
scientific problems by interacting with
complex physical systems on your
computer so we're sort of opening up
this world to ordinary people where they
can like cooperate together and try to
figure out how can we build new drugs
and how can we you know sort of better
humanity in some sense so we have like
90 thousand users and thousand players
and they fold proteins and they compete
with one another and the interesting
thing is that the proteins they're
folding are hopefully actually medically
useful so we take the results of what
the top players are doing and actually
study what they're doing and see if we
can actually synthesize those proteins
and use them to make new enzymes or
interesting that yeah antigens and stuff
like that so yeah it's pretty cool we're
basically asking ordinary people to help
us do science by playing a video game
one of the really inspiring things that
I felt immediately when I came here and
that I feel every day when I walk
through the halls is just how good
everyone here is and it's just an
amazing thing to be able to work with
these people who all sort of have like a
superpower and to want to have a
superpower to and and sort of join
forces with them and fight evil as it
were
scientifically and and that's just
really really exciting place to be and
you just want to work with all these
people and be as good as them and and do
as good work as everyone else is doing
so it's really inspiring that way